hey guys it's justine and today we are
unboxing the hp envy all-in-one and the
box is actually too large to put on the
table so
it's right here a huge thank you to hp
and intel for partnering with me on this
video
let's get into the unboxing oh boy oh
boy this display is huge it's 31.5
inches
and it is 4k which is super
exciting
look at that
hey can you just let me be like
[Music]
wow okay the box was huge this display
is huge
it has a built-in speaker and the thing
that i'm most excited to try out is this
little bottom mount right here
you guys it's a wireless charger
brilliant
okay this is still it's still taking the
whole desk it's so huge i'm gonna put it
on this little side table and see how
that works out while i unbox the rest of
these accessories
love when batteries are included
[Music]
oh this is nice i love
having a full keyboard i use the number
pad
so much more than i ever realized when i
don't have one i always go
it also has this little tray i feel like
that'd be kind of cool to put your phone
or a book
oh yeah oh that's perfect
i love this so much because when i am
doing live streams and stuff i like to
actually have
the chat on my phone we've got our mouse
also bluetooth
i do like this has batteries you can
also get rechargeable ones if you like
but i do like that this doesn't have any
cables you don't have to charge it
you can use it just like this no cables
no nothing this is fantastic
[Music]
that's it
i'm doing business hey justine what are
you doing
business we've got one more box
oh this is this is a beefy power adapter
oh that's a memory card reader thank you
thank you
thank you let's get this thing set up
and talk about some specs
this features 32 gigs of ram one
terabyte solid state drive
and nvidia geforce gtx 1650 graphics
card it has a 10th gen
intel core i7 2.9 gigahertz processor
that redefines what's possible in a thin
and light computer ssds with intel
optane memory deliver the best real
world performance compared to nand ssds
it has easy access to the ports
a built-in powerful bang olufsen speaker
and wireless charging
there's a pop-up privacy camera it's
1920p with an 88 degree wide angle field
of view
and a microphone that is only enabled
when it's in use this display is amazing
it's a 4k 31.5 inch display with wide
color gamut hdr
uhd and anti-reflective coating
basically
this thing looks incredible
so i've been using this computer for the
past couple of days and i absolutely
love it one of the things that i'm most
excited about
is this pop-up camera i use this to do
video calls
i also used it to do a test stream
everything
all in one microphone video am i live
now
i need to move some stuff around in the
background i tried to hide it all
you guys are seeing it hold on a second
what it all that scared me now
streaming live we've got our chat here
everyone's excited and i haven't
streamed in a while so they're probably
like what are you doing where are you
[Music]
this is now going to be a permanent part
of our podcast set we've been looking
for a solution to be able to
record our audio have a screens that
would be able to see our notes
and a way to bring in audio and video of
our guests so because this is able to be
moved around
we have a little desk set up in front of
our podcast desk so i can have this set
up at an actual desk when i'm doing work
or playing games and then just
pick it up and move it in front of the
podcast desk it's so great because this
screen is so huge
that we're able to see the screen see
our guest and i can actually hit record
we can see our notes
and the keyboard and mouse matches the
podcast desk so my sister and i can both
search for things while we're talking
because this is wireless so we're able
to have no cords or wires
and it looks neat in the video portion
of the podcast as well you can't see it
right here because it is off camera and
if you're listening to audio you can't
see it
but i am doing a video of this review
for this hp all-in-one computer it's
amazing and we have it sitting right
next to the camera it's like a huge
screen so we want to search for
something we've got a little mouse we
got a keyboard
yeah this is great although our notes
for today it basically just says podcast
episode 12 and that is completely blank
so we don't have many notes
there's so many little details that i
love about this computer the fact that i
can just
oh look my phone's charging such a great
idea they really did put a lot of
thought into some of the smaller details
like even this
base is like a nice wood finish and
there's some little accents
around here to just make it look really
pretty
the speakers are incredibly loud i was
very shocked when i first tested it out
let me find some royalty-free music for
you guys so you can get a little demo
[Music]
even though it's loud
there's nothing i love more than a good
royalty-free track
podcast episode 13. this is cool because
i can share this with
my sister and she'll be able to also
make edits and notes so that for the
next episode of the podcast we'll be
way more prepared it's great because the
sd card slot is right here on the left
in addition to a headphone port and
there's an easily accessible usb port
over here on the right as well
so i'm going to edit myself a nice photo
for instagram
this was so fun i want to go back to
edit this
this is a raw image add a little grain
to it yeah that looks cool
here's one of me and my sister oh yeah
that's cool here's another one of us let
me save
this so i could post it on instagram
we also got some really cool drone shots
i mean this monitor
just looks amazing it's so crisp
[Music]
what a fun
trip this does have an anti-reflective
screen which is really nice especially
if you're working in places with a lot
of sunlight
we have a lot of studio lights in here
right now so you might be able to see a
little bit of reflections
but having this on here does get rid of
a lot of them
and here's our podcast that we recorded
it's really great because we're able to
just have this off to the side and i'm
able to see
everything that's happening there have
been some times when we were recording
before that we weren't sure if we were
actually recording because i wasn't able
to see
so now this monitor is so huge if we're
not recording i'm going to know about it
interesting i just i like where you
would like just set something
then look at this look at this i'll put
a link in the description where you can
check out all of the options for the hp
mv32 i do have a specked out version so
depending upon where you do get this
the configurations may vary but this
thing has been so amazing i've been
using it for so many different things
gaming podcasting editing photos and the
screen
just really does look incredible if you
guys have any other questions about this
or anything that i talked about in this
video
feel free to leave them in the comments
below again a huge thank you to hp
intel for sponsoring this video you guys
are awesome and i will see you all
in the next video
[Music]
that was actually shocking i did